hey y'all is that Chrissy is he is he
coming at you with that new hotness and
up dude my husband not gonna know what
hit him once he sees this hairstyle but
I must say that though I want my husband
to like how I look I don't need his
approval so this is why I chose this
hairstyle because it's his favorite and
it's also my favorite although I'm being
really honest it's not my absolute
favorite my absolute favorite is just to
wear my hair down but you know our
society doesn't want black women to feel
like that the way that they were born is
sexy or sexual here's how you can
achieve this date night up to you look
inside yourself and you see what you
want and then you tell your guy this is
Who I am and you better get into it and
then he'll say hey I don't care about
your hair I love you for the way you are
and then you'll say yes I'll marry you
time's up gotta go we got reservations
this has been Christie is he saying
don't I look good I know that I do